hit and runs are on the rise all across
the valley and six people have been
killed in hit and run crashes over the
past three months
compared to 10 throughout last year as a
whole thanks for joining us here at five
i'm denise valdez and i'm brian loftis
now video you're seeing right here is
from crashes just last week now police
are asking for the public's help
in solving two of these cases reporter
kate houston is live right near paradise
and twain
that is where one of those crashes
happened kate
yes that's right now metro police say
that they want to break this trend they
say that in both of these cases
the drivers fled the scene leaving
pedestrians to die on the side of the
road
if they stayed right here and helped
they wouldn't have been charged these
are people
and they're dying on our roadways laying
there bleeding to death
dying and nobody did anything to stop
them metro lieutenant greg munson
is pleading to the community after six
people died from hit and run crashes
two of which have not been solved these
families need closure
these families need justice and the
people that responsible
need to face the consequences of their
actions police are searching for this
burgundy suv
saying it was involved in a hit-and-run
crash on february 20
on palos verdes near twain and paradise
a 63-year-old man was walking near that
crosswalk and was hit and killed
the second death happened on march 14th
on lincoln near lake mead and lamb
when a man in his 50's darted across
oncoming traffic
and was hit police are searching for a
2007 to 2009
gray toyota camry that was involved both
of these drivers
left the scene and both of these drivers
if
they would have stayed on scene were not
at fault in this collision
but now they're looking at serious
felony charges now metro is asking
anyone with information to come forward
so they can bring these families
closure somebody knows something a
person doesn't just hit and kill
somebody on a road and remain completely
silent
somebody's friend their family their
co-worker knows that they did this
back out live that first crash did
happen right near this intersection
if you have any information anonymous
tips can be made through crime stoppers
the lvmpd traffic bureau is also taking
tips
on their facebook page through messenger
reporting live near paradise and twain
kate houston
8 news now